Anthony here is helping me pick out what
I should be wearing for this photo shoot
this works long as you you gotta give me
pointers and precise I am NOT a model I
know that Casey good morning guys
so today we're gonna be doing a
go-for-broke photo shoot
he's actually doing a barbell Brigade
shoot today so she's not gonna be
joining us but we're loading up now you
guys are gonna come along with me today
hey we're already got love enough to go
this bad guys
the first bomber going to this is a
military museum we're gonna make this
one quick we have to fake this photo
shoot at this spot so we can't make it
seem like it's a photo shoot we'll just
you know scatter like we're two versus
stuff oh cool it's go right here where
the comments oh nice
as cool as women as though play with
these props and they let us use for
photos too excited for this photo shoot
yeah like this morning I was like
straining my hair it got like really
messy I like Josh shampoo it is and
there's like white stuff there you look
good though girl thank you
I like the blue how about you girl you
excited pretty excited a little nervous
at the same time yeah
have you ever modeled before I had one
bad experience before that kind of
trauma type you tell me I did it once
before when I was younger I just wasn't
used to it so I kind of got
uncomfortable and then I kind of
traumatized I never did it again
we'd be like what about it traumatized
you so the photographer what kind of
just telling me like he was giving me
outfits to wear and then at one point
he's like you know was a shirt probably
look better if you can wear Aperol know
and also young stuff like I felt kind of
violated yeah after that I was like I'm
not gonna do it again there's a negative
bit here right now and I'll grow now
you're with friends people you can trust
that's not trying to look at your movie
exactly yeah we get square for all yeah
I think so we're good yay yeah so here
we are at this American military museum
where we don't officially have
permission to be shooting photos or
anything like that but I mean they see
us with the cameras and they're not
saying anything so we're just kind of
going with the flow here called guerilla
style shooting this place is pretty cool
though there's a lot of really cool like
retired military vehicles we can't even
touch these these vehicles which is
understandable I mean imagine if they
just let tourists get in these tank you
can't trust people yeah they even gave
us these props though it's pretty cool
feel pretty badass here wait let's get
it up close so this real quick close-up
on my boogers
check out Michael modeling like a motto
look at these pant legs it's okay though
because he's that she's only shooting
waist up so it's okay all right yeah how
does it feel modeling because we're not
modeled no at all it's hard for me
because I feel like I have to be serious
but I'm not a very serious person so
every time I see people trying to be
cool my man I want to be zapped that's
just imagining myself being cold you
like I know that's gonna challenge us is
like yeah we just photo shoots always
get in this like mood of where it's like
climbing I got a I got a make fun of it
so the only way I can model like with KC
every time like we're vlogging the other
and he's like all right give me some
model shots in slow-mo on my bike
because I don't know I don't model like
so much respect to you real MA this is
hard because you have to worry about
like contouring be wrinkly like like
yeah like making your body like have
curves and then also focusing that your
face looks nice and not it is so much
work I kind of has this like myself out
and be like alright
just work it for the camera don't let
this isn't silly it that's what I'm
telling myself in my head today but
today you said you felt really
comfortable why do you think that was oh
yeah
I don't know I guess like shooting with
like all of our friends and so intimate
it's so relaxed and there's not that
pressure of like all these eyeballs on
you and it's I don't know today has been
way more chill for me and I'm glad it's
been like that because I don't want to
get and these like weird silly movies
hopefully it it stays like that
participate you know what I think
something else that's helping me it's
because we are all models today it's not
just me so that helps a lot too because
you're in this too Michael that is true
like I never modeled but I feel like
because I'm with friends today it feels
very comfortable and hopefully the
results are as good as I hope they are
you know Hey hopefully damn scared oh
yeah - lunch time
thank you
[Music]
I'll turn up I guess he's like yeah like
if I can't is not here because we love
the dkc you can eat pho whenever you
want see they're all eating stuff you
see I don't stop you from eating it your
fault
life is not here yet I just ordered two
little spring roll singing what I even
that hungry we had breakfast not that
long ago I don't know how you guys build
up an appetite so soon I didn't have
breakfast I didn't eat that McDonald's
you guys do oh sure like Rito on
McDonald's I feel like it's unhealthy
that's very in there is like maybe it is
macro friendly but it is also like
chemicals in that food but Oliver
streams are full right there I know I
just saw so much 30 minutes flexing oh
yeah I look way bigger in person
[Music]
we roll to the beach we have an entire
rack of clothes rags all right now we're
at the second location in Laguna Beach
Crystal Cove see right here
evidence that's I'm not lying Kimmy what
would I like rolling a lot of stuff
except me just have the camera on my
back does that make me a bad friend oh
okay hold on there we go okay see now
I'm helping this thing something that's
really light and feels really hot boy
okay there we go I got it yeah
go shoot some more photos and videos
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
really rocket I don't know I was still
like be careful hula oh you did it so
easy oh man my turn
there you go there you go there you go
first up and I was eating that guy oh
he's eating him no save yourself where
you trying to save him no no he was just
a baby and Mochan
[Music]
run run run run we're running out of the
sunlight we're trying to get the very
last shots now all right so we're
nearing the end of the shoots because
obviously we ran out of sunlight so it's
my last look but yeah today has been so
fun and it's been a really cool
experience have you felt it was really
fun and we're pretty comfortable oh yeah
it got really really really fun after
like you know seeing all of us shoot and
I think each of us started getting more
and more comfortable because we see each
other shoot and then it's not only like
one person right and we're like feeding
off of each other's energy too so it's
like hey Joe I feel like I did the same
look for every photo like that that's
just the type of person I am like I can
only smile and photos and if I'm not
smiling I'm doing the same thing that's
it I only have to look she worked it
yeah make it yeah you're so sweet but
you know like you had the lips too
do i I mean I don't know how to do it
how do i how do i utilize it you just
like kind of I don't know maybe like a
little clumpiness I guess maybe when
you're like kinda like sick
so funny just like this
[Music]
be serious now
[Applause]